hey guys it's justine and phone season
is officially here and a huge thank you
to lifeproof for sponsoring a portion of
this video
and i'm really excited to show you guys
these weight cases that they've made
because they are made from 85
ocean-based recycled plastic
like old fishing nets ropes and tackle
and if you guys are familiar with
lifeproof you know that their cases are
always very drop resistant so you can
drop these up to two meters and your
phone will be safe so not only
are you saving your phone but you're
also saving the planet it's so crazy to
think that over 12 million metric tons
of plastic ends up in our oceans
every single year so it's really great
to know that some of that is now being
turned into
iphone cases so when you buy any
lifeproof case they've partnered with
water conscious non-profits who are
working to help heal the ocean you get
to pick the cause and they will donate a
dollar they have tons of different cases
for all sorts of phones so feel free to
head over to their website i'll put a
link in the description if you want to
check it out and here i have
some of their new ones i really like
this purple too
check that out this little teal color
black so nice thanks again to lifeproof
for sponsoring a portion of this video
and for all that you guys are doing to
help push this environmental cause
forward
it's really amazing and i'm so happy to
be a small part of it so for the rest of
this video i just kind of wanted to talk
to you guys about how
i've been liking these phones so far now
i have had the iphone 12
pro and the 12 for
about three weeks so maybe like over a
month actually
and i did just recently get the pro max
and the mini and there's so many
similarities across
all four of these devices this year that
i really do feel like
any phone that you guys end up getting
you're going to be
so so happy about the one main question
that a lot of people have been asking me
is if they should upgrade if they have
an 11 pro
or an 11 pro max and i honestly don't
think that you should if you do have the
extra money
then yes go for it but the 11 pro and 11
pro max are such
incredible phones we went out to joshua
tree and we were shooting some photos
and tyler was shooting a lot on his 11
pro max and i was shooting obviously a
lot on my 12 and he posted some photos
and a lot of people were asking him if
those were shot on the 12. so the
cameras are very similar in the 11 and
the 12s but where you're getting the
differences
is in the 12 pro max with the upgraded
telephoto to 2.5 x
and with the larger sensor in the
wide-angle lens
and because these phones are much faster
than the previous gen that is allowing
them to do things like the dolby vision
hdr
which honestly is not a hundred percent
necessary i've said this so many times
before but when apple does something it
integrates something like hdr
it kind of gives us all that little
gentle nudge that says all right now's
the time we need to figure out a good
workflow how to use hdr
because this is it's here it's here and
we need to figure it out so i haven't
worked much with
exporting hdr content but i have worked
with hdr footage
turning it into sdr for things like
youtube so i have come up with a few
workflows that have been working for me
and even what i'm doing technically
is not correct like i know what i'm
doing this is not how i should be
delivering this footage
if i was in school i would probably be
in trouble because i would not be doing
it the proper way but it's working and
it's looking really good when i end up
exporting that content to youtube so
that's one of the reasons why i haven't
actually made a video talking about my
hdr workflow because it technically
isn't correct
so i don't want to be putting this
knowledge out there of the way that i'm
doing something
it's not really the way that you should
be doing it but it's working so i'm kind
of having this internal battle with
myself
final cut doesn't actually support the
dolby vision hdr right now so i think in
the next iteration
and with big sur it will so right now
you are able to edit and work with hdr
content but you're not able to export
the dolby vision metadata to actually
have it be
dolby vision hdr i know it's just it's a
lot it's a lot that most
normal people don't even need to worry
about like you just want to shoot
and take good content on your phone and
that's
what these do that's what they're doing
you guys are doing a very good job of it
i must say i do want to show you what i
have done
with my home screens in comparison the
old way that i was setting up my phone
i've just got apps on apps on apps and i
used to put them
all in like these separate little
folders which was fine
because i don't ever actually go into
these folders to click to do anything i
always swipe down
and i search for whatever it is that i
want so now
what i'm doing on my new devices is
i'm not putting thing on any page
except my home screen so you'll see i do
have a little space here
for another app okay so
i might have lied to you because i
haven't got a chance to update this but
my plan
is to only have apps on the first page
anything that i would be using on a
daily basis
and the rest of these things like okay
peloton i do use quite often
so i'm basically gonna take peloton so
not delete app but remove from home
screen
venmo yeah we're gonna remove you you're
gonna
oh my god now i'm getting notifications
on every single phone
what is happening so now i'm just able
to swipe over and i have my entire app
library
everything is here it's also neat it's
so organized
oh my gosh so when you have three phones
that are getting notifications
i'm gonna go i'm getting silly after
tech season i'm gonna take some time off
and i'm going to go be alone with myself
and i'm going to hide my phone
from myself i've also decided to just
put one single
simple little widget here i like this
widget because it shows me my news
it shows me what's coming up on my
calendar and it also will show me a
random photo
but for whatever reason my phone kept
showing me this photo
i have hundreds and thousands of photos
that you can choose from
and this is the one that you decided
that i should see i just i don't get it
oh this one's cute this is a little one
of maddie and me
uh the photos though on the pro max are
very impressive i think my favorite
thing is
the telephoto the 2.5 x zoom
is really really cool
i didn't think that it was going to make
a big difference until i saw something
like this
let me show you so i showed these photos
in my photo test
so here's our ultra wide and here's the
wide
pretty much the same but then here's the
2x
versus the two and a half x so you can
definitely tell that there's so much
more zoom in that
and i really just can't believe how
great it is like look at this ready
zoom zoom maddie zoom i think he had a
good time in joshua tree
i'm not sure
[Music]
i was also incredibly impressed with the
low light performance and what's cool is
the low
light on all of these cameras also
impressive
they have night mode on the front on all
three cameras on the 12
pro and then also on the 12 the two rear
facing cameras and even the front facing
also has night mode
it just made me really happy to see that
they didn't skimp on some of the lower
end models
i do wish that they had the same cameras
on the two pro models
but i feel like you do need to have
another reason to upgrade
to the pro max and something that you're
gonna
really notice if you do get this phone
and you've compared it to the 11
is the size of the lenses
so i don't know if you can really tell
but
the 12 pro max like the lenses are way
thicker i mean we're talking very
very small increments but when you are
putting them up next to each other
like the 11 it's very flat and the 12
pro it's like whoa there's a difference
so obviously you are getting that new
censorship technology which will help
with the stabilization of the video and
even the photos
and now that this has the lidar it
really does assist
with focus and being able to get better
low light performance
when you're trying to focus on different
subjects because the lidar is basically
not relying on the light so much so it's
using that lidar sensor to determine the
depth so i'm
very pleased with the upgrades that they
made this year and that's not even to
mention 5g
but when i tested out the 5g uw and some
other videos that you guys
may have seen the speeds that i was
getting i'm getting like two and a half
gigs
down like that is just unheard of and
when that becomes the future and when
that becomes the norm
the possibilities are endless editing in
the cloud what this is gonna do
for autonomous driving because every car
will be able to have this incredibly
fast connection
we'll be constantly getting this
information faster quicker and more
efficiently
it's really going to change everything i
don't think people really understand the
importance of 5g and the future of it
because right now it just sort of is a
buzzword it's like oh this is 5g
what no it's going to be cool and when
it is everywhere and in our homes
i am going to be so excited because my
internet
is trash well thank you guys for
watching i just wanted to address some
of the questions that i've been getting
and also talk a little bit about what
i've been doing on my phones and
obviously if you guys have been
following me
here on youtube or twitter instagram you
know exactly what i've been doing
probably better than anybody else i will
see you guys in my next video
and if you have any other questions feel
free to leave them in the comments below
and i will either try to answer them
here
on youtube or in a future video so until
then i'll see you guys later
bye
you